hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for anime uproar and today
i will be discussing the latest events
in the boku no hero
story including more reveals about the
true nature of
deku's quirk i will also talk about why
i think that deku
is about to make a huge mistake
a mistake that could cost many innocent
lives and completely
change deku as a person the theory that
we are about to go through a very dark
time skip
in boku no hero is getting more and more
plausible
so let's get into it if you enjoyed the
boku no hero content here on the channel
and you want us to keep it going please
leave a like
and comment it only takes a second but
it really does help
and if you are new to anime out pro or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video do you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all i know it's annoying but if you
don't do that you're still gonna miss a
ton of our videos it's just how youtube
works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
anime uproar finally this video will of
course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been
warned so in the previous chapter we had
that whole reveal about deku
possibly being the final one for all
user and
then at the very end of the chapter the
vestige of nana shimura
looked deku right in the eye and asked
him whether he would be able to kill
her grandson tomura shigaraki by the way
am i the only one who thinks that nana
is looking
pretty damn good in that first panel of
chapter 305 like i realize that is in no
way relevant to the story but still damn
anyway nana explains to deku that the
vestiges can
sense the same thoughts and feelings
that deku is sensing
and during that fight with shigaraki
deku saw that deep on the inside
shigaraki is just a crying child who is
in terrible pain
the vestiges of the former one for all
users can also sense that shigaraki
is being hurt by all for one but
that doesn't mean that shiraki wants or
would even accept help
from the heroes he is still full of
hatred for the hero society
and he is still a murderous villain
shigaraki has been
shaped and manipulated by all for one
from a very young
age and at this point all for one is
pretty much controlling shigaraki's body
not just in terms of psychological
manipulation which he has been doing all
along
but physically as well this puts deku
and the former users
in a difficult situation on the one hand
killing shigaraki would eliminate him as
a threat and
probably save many innocent lives but on
the other hand
since shigaraki is also a victim of all
for one
just killing him seems cruel and unfair
we then learn more about one for all as
a quirk and particularly the question of
whether
it can ever be stolen as we know all for
one has been trying to steal one
for all for decades and in fact daigo
robonjo explains that
all for one tried to steal one for all
from him and from his successor
all for one failed both times but in
order for one for all to remain
safe from all for one every successor
must have an
iron will and infinite determination
in the past we've been told that one for
all cannot be transferred to someone
else without the consent
of the current user and that has led
many people to conclude that one for all
can never be stolen period
i know from comments on my mha videos
that many people out there believe that
one for all can never be stolen and that
all for one is just
wasting his time but that never made
sense to me
would all for one a criminal mastermind
with dozens of quirks
at his disposal really be stupid enough
to spend
decades of his life trying to achieve
something that was always straight up
impossible if all for one is so
committed to stealing one for all
and if he's been trying to do it for
generations then he must believe that
stealing the quirk
is indeed possible and this particular
conversation between deku and the former
users does seem to suggest that the
user's willpower
plays some role in whether or not one
for all can be stolen
it seems that one for all cannot be
stolen if the user has very strong
willpower and determination
but maybe it can be stolen if the user
falters
and loses his or her determination for
whatever reason
nana then explains to deku that tomorrow
is her grandson who became what he is
today because she abandoned
his father at a young age in that sense
shigaraki's tragic fate is the indirect
result of nana's
own actions nana knows that her failure
to defeat all for one
is to blame for what shigaraki has
become and she feels terrible about now
trying to place the burden of killing
him upon a 16 year old boy
but nana also knows that if the newly
awakened shigaraki
reaches his full potential nothing will
be able to stop
him he will become the pure
manifestation of evil
and his power will be beyond
comprehension deku understands
this difficult predicament but he
explains that back when he had faced off
against
shigaraki he got a brief glimpse into
the deepest parts of shigaraki's mind
and there deku could feel that shigaraki
the real shigaraki or i guess i should
say
tenko shimura was just a crying
child he was still that young boy who
was abused by his father
and then pushed to the breaking point by
the sudden appearance of his deadly
quirk
deku says that one for all is a power
meant for saving people
not for killing people all might taught
him that important lesson
and so even though there is a strong
possibility that the only way to stop
shigaraki
will be to kill him deku still wants to
try to save him
he still wants to try saving that crying
child
the first one for all user is glad to
hear this
and he vows that the former users are
here to guide
deku on this journey nana then
apologizes for testing deku with such a
difficult question
but both she and the first user are very
happy that deku was the one who became
their successor
nana regrets that she and gran torino
abandoned shigaraki's father in order to
focus on fighting all for one
but she is now pinning all of her hopes
on
deku she hopes that deku can find a way
to rescue that little crying boy her
grandson
from the clutches of all for one on the
final page of this chapter
the first one for all user turns to the
other two users the second user
and the third user those are the two
guys who are just standing in the
background and facing the wall
the first one for all user tells them to
chime in
and tell deku what to expect from their
quirks and that is how this
chapter ends man horikoshi has really
piqued my curiosity about these two
mysterious
former users who were they and why are
they going out of their way to hide
their faces from
deku and what information are they about
to reveal i've heard some crazy theories
about these two
like the theory that the guy whose hair
looks like bakugou's is actually bakugo
from the future who somehow traveled to
the past
but i really don't know what to think
did these guys do something bad
during their lives and they are hiding
because they're ashamed
or do they have extremely powerful
quirks which are difficult to master
and so they are hiding from deku until
he is strong enough to handle their
quirks because maybe if he manifests
them too early
they could actually hurt him definitely
let me know what you guys think about
these two users down
in the comments why are they hiding and
what kind of quirks do you think they
possess
now i want to talk a bit about this
whole deku trying to save shigaraki
thing
i think that deku might be making a huge
mistake by trying to save shigaraki
instead of killing him yes it's true
that shigaraki was manipulated by all
for one
and it's true that all for one is now
trying to control shigaraki against his
will but we have to remember that
despite being a victim of all for one
shigaraki is still a murderous villain
he still killed a whole bunch of people
even when he wasn't being directly
controlled by all for one so
this is not just some misunderstood
anti-hero we're talking about here
shigeraki is a ruthless mass murderer
and even if you like him as a character
you have to admit that from a hero's
perspective
killing shigaraki is by far the most
practical solution
to me the shigeru situation is similar
to the dobby situation
yes dabi was victimized by his father
when he was still a child and yes that
was
unfair but dobby is an adult now
and he alone is responsible for the
decisions that he makes
as an adult it's not endeavour's fault
that he chose to become a villain
and kill a whole bunch of people it's
dobby's fault
and the same goes for shigaraki he is no
longer that
crying kid like yes he still has scars
from that time
scars which clearly haven't healed but
when shigaraki decided to reduce the
entire hospital in jakku to ashes
killing multiple people in the process
he made that decision
on his own when he decided to undergo
ujico's procedure in the first place
he made that decision on his own when he
decided to become the leader of the
paranormal liberation front he made that
decision on his own and so on now yes
ideally deku won't have to kill
shigaraki he'll just be able to capture
him
and send him to prison but what if the
next time the deck when shigaraki meet
conditions are not ideal what if deku
finds himself in a situation where he
either has to kill shigaraki now
or let him get away will deku let
shigaraki escape
because he wants to save him and will
shigaraki then go on to kill a bunch of
people later
because deku let him get away how would
deku react if this
came to pass how would deku ever forgive
himself if he allowed shigaraki to
escape
and then innocent people died as a
result of him letting shigaraki escape
i feel like deku would never forgive
himself for that he would be absolutely
traumatized and he would be turned into
a completely different person
by that trauma that is why i believe
that trying to save shigaraki
could be a huge mistake as an adult
shigaraki had a chance to make his own
decisions
and those decisions have sometimes led
to the deaths of innocent people
so shigaraki is not some well-meaning
guy with a heart of gold who just made
some mistakes
shigaraki is a killer and he will kill
again
if given the chance and the longer
shigaraki stays alive
the stronger he will become because of
ujjiko's procedure
so yeah allowing shigaraki to live could
be a
very big mistake i can of course
understand
why nana wants to save her grandson and
i can understand why a hero like deku
would want to avoid
killing anyone but this is not an ideal
world and sometimes you have to make
difficult choices or you will suffer the
consequences
whatever happens though it's going to be
very very
interesting i am extremely curious to
see what's going to happen next in the
story and i can't wait
to learn more about those two mysterious
former users
also does anyone else get the vibe that
nana and gran torino were in a romantic
relationship
like i don't know if gran torino is
shigaraki's grandfather or just someone
nana was with
after having her son with someone else
but i've been getting romantic vibes
from nana and gran torino for a long
time am i the only one
feel free to share your thoughts and
feedback down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more boku no hero content right
here on the channel please leave a like
to let me know
it really does help and if you are new
to anime pro
or maybe you've been watching our videos
but you haven't subscribed yet make this
the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all
notifications you could also hit me up
on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar a big thank you to all
of our anime outpour patrons for making
videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
the world a quiet respect pate heffa
liam thompson
algertal dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku spidey life chanel baked
buddhist and tungsten tarkis
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers on hell cruise
anatoly kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica califond
rathune de ora
alicia octor bonnie parks hinokami and
water the red-haired raven joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games ted no
ted
deadly saint matthew cruz and anthony
schreiber
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you